[Music]
in celebrity beef news tell me the drama
submitted by JC JC chasse the initials
JC not pronounced like JC JC JC because
it sounds like lazy yeah it wouldn't be
lettuce we call Casey Casey Casey sounds
way better now then whenever we order
food or something you always be like
Casey like a K and a seat
I always KC masterpiece though I was
wondering like how you would yell at
somebody in like a like an Internet
language cantonese have to like go down
right like you have to go yeah like if
you have to yell at Casey Casey how do
you commit to that [ __ ] you speak Korean
but you add your own [ __ ] oh yeah oh
[ __ ] you have none but you put them in
there I don't know what you're saying
huh la Lana Del Rey is now fighting with
Azealia Banks over Kanye West
I saw this on Twitter I didn't
understand it Lana so Peter tell ray
real I don't like Azealia Banks she
fights for everybody she is so [ __ ]
is she like the keemstar of the frickin
hip-hop rolls like the most she's like
she makes everything like she thinks
everything is anti black lankey she she
first was like at this forefront of like
defending black culture was anything a
lot of people [ __ ] with but then she
kind of just went from there too much
you know like everything is anti black
everything is that what she the
sensitive [ __ ] that was on okay same
girl is she in her own world she is even
give a [ __ ] about like this mainstream
pop [ __ ] I thought well that's a
good picture of her is it yeah she looks
she looks like trash she looks like Katt
Williams in a dress
I was thinking Martin yeah we'll have
Martin Lawrence's she looks like hey yes
they were fighting over this photo that
Kanye posted was that Mike Rashid the
mega yeah the mega hat and I'm
officially officially I'm denounced this
fool now I don't [ __ ] with this guy at
all
whatever 100 percent for reals I think
he's a hundred number one I think his
music is not good anymore
what about salsa you know this all music
starts playing you're gonna start seeing
the lyric I'll [ __ ] with the old Kanye
the new Kanye anything else that he does
from here on out I can't [ __ ] with him
anymore just because I think he is one
of the most irresponsible human beings
ever I only like college dropout he
didn't pay his taxes he's such a he's
such a culture mover but he doesn't give
a [ __ ] you know what I mean so like what
do you mean what do you mean what you
mean he is so [ __ ] influential no
matter what he says people follow that
follow him die hard yeah but he doesn't
give a [ __ ] and he doesn't care about
the repercussions of what he says
scooping poop
Scooby pop pop something like this right
wearing the maggot him as a as a black
American that's completely fine that's
okay but he doesn't take responsibility
for the repercussions it has for him
being a huge black influence of wearing
that hat and putting out in the
forefront he what he won't he won't
acknowledge it he goes well that's just
my form of expression which is very
American it's true but you don't realize
how that makes your people feel and you
won't recognize it I think you're
missing the point of why he's wearing
the hat his his stance is basically why
can't black people be Republicans too
that's true but the point is that he
won't recognize is that how he says it
and how he delivers his whoa yeah he
can't articulate for [ __ ] exactly it's
like a crackhead
but because I get where he's coming from
and because of his connection to Candis
Owens and and what she preaches I can
see what he's trying to do and it comes
from a good place I think so but it's
just done so horrible so I'm saying
that's the irresponsible part I don't
like cuz I don't know I don't think he's
being irresponsible for the sake of
being irresponsible I think he's just
dumb he's just a passionate person that
can't speak what super uber genius yeah
because he knows how to stir controversy
maybe maybe he's a marketing genius I
don't know if he's goober genius um I
still [ __ ] with them cuz I mean I'm just
a Kanye fan
and his last album was trashed I don't
give a [ __ ] when anybody says that [ __ ]
was trash dude I liked it it was so
[ __ ] like the thing about Kanye that
I loved about his music demos is that
every time he came out with the album it
was something that was unique to him and
he was always a trendsetter his last
album was what everybody else was doing
the beats the cadence the rhymes
everything that [ __ ] was trash I don't
give a [ __ ] what anybody says he's also
not in the outside find me outside if
you [ __ ] with that album a hundred
percent and you said that was vintage
Kanye your [ __ ] rock that was not
vintage Kanye I don't give a [ __ ] man
vintage Connie is not he'd he died on
the 808 heartbreak but like before that
he was gone
even with 808 and heartbreak I didn't
like it very much kind of implied with
it but check that [ __ ] out though a
couple years later everybody was on that
dinner everybody that's how much of a
trendsetter he was that's how much I
liked him I was like damn I may not like
it now but I bet you he's gonna start
something else this last thing was what
everybody else he's something like a
little pump lil Zen little [ __ ] you
didn't like him in the big square is so
bad so bad pink um he's also going
through a really weird mental state to
the last time I think what set it off
was that concert
remember that concert where he left and
then it was like a huge controversy and
then he he met he had a meltdown the
jay-z thing he was like jay-z don't send
you killers after me so he thought the
whole world was against them he comes
back finds out that he was you know
super on meds or too much meds or not
taking his meds or something and then
now he's on this whole thing about like
he's against the pharmaceuticals because
of what it's done to him
and I think a lot of it is like he's not
the same Kanye that we knew because he
was more grounded back then now he's
just insane I think he needs to go do a
Dave Chappelle and go to Africa or
something dude decide he needs to chill
out
unplug chilla he that's hard man his
wife is like in the epitome she's like
the top he deleted his Twitter and
everything else again I guess because
Kim asked him to cuz it's like [ __ ]
with this head and I guess he is like
clinically bipolar yeah and so that's a
huge issue you know and as long as he's
away from that and I think like that
poll kind of makes it a little better
but I will say this I don't even [ __ ]
with his new shoes anymore either dude
the [ __ ] I don't even know home
issues yeah it's like
I'd shoot dad shoot they look like the
panacea
I don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ] do you see
those [ __ ] Balenciaga and all those
[ __ ] so trash I think he's lost
connection there like big ass what about
[ __ ] bees though look at these
Balenciaga standard yo I bet you though
you put Balenciaga on that [ __ ]
everybody will [ __ ] this looks fast
it's so [ __ ] what all those shoes of
legit
you need a [ __ ] walker with tennis
balls they should come with it's so
[ __ ] wack that should be the [ __ ]
marketing can be so dull the next part
about marketing campaign so what's going
on with la Llana and yeah so the photo I
just showed you guys with Kanye the
caption says this represents good and
America becoming whole again we will no
longer outsourced to other countries we
build factories here in America and
create jobs
we will provide jobs for all who are
free from prison who's writing this this
is Connie okay yeah we will provide jobs
for all who are free from prisons as we
abolish the 13th amendment message sent
with love I don't even know the 13 like
the abolishment of slavery yeah
so it says neither slavery nor
involuntary servitude except as a
punishment for crime whereof the party
shall have been duly convicted shall
exist yeah it's just really sad that
he's not in the right place because with
the the message that he's trying to give
now if he was old Kanye blending it in
with his music I think it would have
been great like he's doing to two really
strong points as of late is one is
against the pharmaceutical industry and
the other one is really the the would
you call it you know identity politics
and how people are kind of brainwashed
into being a part of a group like if
we're minority were born into being a
liberal if you're you know white
American in the mid in the Sun and and
in like the rural countryside then
you're born into being a Republican so
it's very divisive and it's not
encouraging to become like oh let's be
one nation in like work together
everyone's like [ __ ] you know [ __ ] you
your race is know you're [ __ ] races
ah
sis yeah that's the that's this is the
type of [ __ ] that I'm talking about it's
super irresponsible to say stuff like
that you know exactly everyone's a
choice yeah how the [ __ ] are we supposed
to know what you mean dude yeah what I
mean and then he sits there and then he
goes on TMZ and he's like let me explain
myself and then his explanation is even
more stupid than his statement man
you gotta give him a beat that's why
he's too much hard and not enough brain
dude if you've got [ __ ] perpetually
like teenager yeah and that's the thing
like you as an adult you're supposed to
be like the voice of reason and he's
supposed to be like quote unquote the
reason for it I guess like youth right
and I'm not saying that all celebrities
have that on their shoulders but at this
point you've become a culture mover your
shoes when they go out everybody wants
it your clothes anything you say is gold
platinum whatever so if you understand
that you putting out an irresponsible
statement like that makes me not want to
[ __ ] with you anymore like your shoes
whatever all the shoes that I bought
right now I'm keeping but from here on
out though no more just because you
don't like the style yeah it's pretty
ugly comment it on that post
she said Trump becoming our president
was a loss for the country but your
support of him is a loss for the culture
I can only assume you relate to his
personality on some level delusions of
grandeur extreme issues with narcissism
none of which would be a talking point
if we weren't speaking about the man
leading our country if you think it's
alright to support someone who believes
it's okay to grab a woman by the [ __ ]
just because he's famous then you need
an intervention as much as he does
something so many narcissist will never
get because they there just isn't enough
help for the issue message with concern
that will never be addressed why not
though dad I know it's wrong and I don't
know if you ever did it but the phrase
grab a woman by the [ __ ] is one of the
best lines I've ever heard in my life so
ridiculous it's pretty yeah it's just so
no one there's no handle there's not a
handle bar there that is like it's like
a [ __ ] WWF killer move or something
there's like more to that quote - I
think they only took that small piece
out but it was like it was like some
kind of I don't know I don't want to get
into it but I was like oh trouble is a
you're saying like yeah you're famous
you want to see you they just want to
just want to [ __ ] ya like no they will
they let you grab it by the cuz there's
some [ __ ] like that I forgot I don't
know whatever it was I was like oh
that's kind of not fair how the media
did that it was weird
but I don't know okay well what a daily
a bank said to Lana was WOW okay Lana
this would be cute if you were
consistent with your outrage and refused
to collaborate with ASAP Rocky who has
physically assaulted women - to me this
just looks like the typical white woman
taking boys about race you gotta make it
about race to me this looks like the
typical white woman taking using a
weakened target to pretend to be in LA
taking using two things I [ __ ] hate
about this she's making it about race
and I [ __ ] hate people using this word
Ally again dude like it's like the
hottest word right now it's like if you
want to be an ally and Ally shut the
[ __ ] up all of your axis or yeah you
want to be an ally are you gonna be an
ally why is that the hot [ __ ] word
right now dude it's like I want you to
be an ally to this cause what the [ __ ]
does that mean dude like I don't
understand team member move it dude man
is so [ __ ] annoying you [ __ ] sheep
yeah oh yes I mean Lana Del Rey responds
with you know Adi pull up any time say
it to my face but dude you wanna go I
won't not [ __ ] you the [ __ ] up period
doubleday give me that [ __ ] I won't not
this is summertime I know
closet
kickboxing [ __ ] chap cuz like some
people just just surprise you like Ed
O'Neill like [ __ ] Al Bundy
yeah is a [ __ ] jujitsu chant yeah
like there's like people out there like
what they can fight you know who's been
training like a [ __ ] where's
Kalifa but he sucks
Thomas new Punk
I Love You Man but keep those bodyguards
cuz I don't think you can do anything
you you're you're fighting his trash
dude that comes from a guy who's
fighting his trash dude yeah so just to
sum all this up here banks responded by
saying that she's gonna be suing Lana
Del Rey Wow why he has nothing masseur
whoa why don't they go that's like the
least hard thing to do why don't they go
you to my dad's a lawyer yeah they
should they should do a pay-per-view
boxing match oh yeah I'll be awesome I
didn't want to see celebrities fight me
too she walks out the summertime sadness
yeah I heard Azealia Banks is a dope
rapper though I haven't listened to any
of your music by her she's [ __ ] dope
though no and then at the end of that
when Azalea was like where's the pull-up
tweet I'm talking to my lawyer Lana Del
Rey's says tell him it's a promise not a
threat oh she don't give up I want to
see them fight
[Music]
[Music]